[Music]
I had a vision
people burning
everything destroyed it was Athena she
was doing it
I was doing it we won't let that happen
I saw what you did in the ring
I knew it had to be you say
what if I told you Sienna here is The
Reincarnation of the goddess Athena
and you are destined to become one of
her Guardian Knights
feel to be a goddess sometimes I feel
like I'm a guest in my own
are you ready to start your training the
Pegasus night is Brave
humble
and committed to protecting Athena with
his life
how the hell did you do that
I wore that Oasis is unlike any other
before
I must save the rest of us from her
you think I wanted any of this
powers of liability and she learns to
control it no living man will be able to
stop
you might want to buckle up
thought you were the only night in town